[Musique]
depuis le début de la semaine les
États-Unis assistent à un véritable
déballage au procès qui opposent Johnny
Depp à son ex-compagne Amber Heard une
affaire qui passionne les hauts Johnny
Depp se retrouve à nouveau devant les
tribunaux face à son ex-femme Amber
Heard message privé enregistrement audio
vidéo tout est passé au peigne fin pour
comprendre la personnalité des deux
individus si lors d'un précédent procès
contre le Sun Vanessa Paradis qui a
partagé la vie de Johnny Depp avait
témoigné en sa faveur nous avons été
partenaire pendant 14 ans et avons élevé
ensemble deux enfants durant toutes ces
années j'ai toujours connu Johnny comme
étant une personne et un père gentil
attentif généreux et non violent
celui-ci ne lui a pas rendu l'appareil
lors de son procès en diffamation qui se
déroule actuellement en effet la
défendant heart aurait lieu un ancien
mail de Johnny Depp qui humilie
totalement Vanessa Paradis mes enfants
sont tombés perduement amoureux d'Ember
et cela m'enlève une énorme pression à
moins que l'extorsque française Aix
[ __ ] ne tente de leur laver le
cerveau par ailleurs Johnny Depp aurait
révéler avoir trompé la chanteuse avec
ramber déjà en 2009 Vanessa Paradis ne
risque pas de reprendre sa défense de
sitôt bon bah je vois qu'une question à
vous poser est-ce que Johnny Depp est un
bâtard
je trouve que le fait que l'audience
soit publique et retransmise dans les
médias bien complètement le procès là on
a l'impression effectivement comme vous
dites que c'est un bâtard mais en fait
il ne l'a pas affiché publiquement ce
sont des échanges privés qui ont été
sortis par la partie adverse elle la
défendait publiquement lui il a le droit
d'avoir son avis de le donner dans un
cadre privé donc il ne l'a pas trahi
publiquement et je trouve que ce
tribunal médiatique au sens propre du
terme il est très dangereux parce que ça
biaise la vie tout le monde tout le
monde y va de son petit commentaire et
juge la faire à la place de la vous
savez qu'en Amérique les procès sont
tous retransmis donc c'est une
particularité américaine c'est des
people ça intéresse tout évidemment sur
Youtube ça fait des millions de vues en
tout cas en sur France 3 on va le faire
dès la rentrée la diffusion de
[Musique]
reports on a plein d'épisodes avec tous
tes divorce normalement on a 6 ans
d'antenne
[ __ ] que ce soit en privé ou pas ça
reste la
elle publie déjà c'était il l'avait
trompé avec Amber et tout ça donc déjà
il avait fait preuve de ça la tromperie
voilà qui qui n'a pas trompé de
si ça devient n'importe quoi
alors est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que Bertrand Deckers
comme dit si bien Cyril cousin de black
est-ce que vous avez
ce que vous avez des infos des infos
là c'est un une lettre en réalité
adressée à ça
il balance ses informations ce que je
peux peut-être apporter un tout petit
peu comme petite éclairage et
apparemment il est ruiné il a plus
d'argent il a plu
franchement ça me rassure mais il a plus
d'argent venez de la maison Dior où on
le rappelle il est l'égérie de sauvage
qui est quand même ce parfum qui est le
plus vendu dans le monde
rappelons aussi que son son ex-compagne
Vanessa Paradis et sa fille Lily-Rose
sont elles des ambassadrices de chez
Chanel et elle elle devrait rester
ambassadrice de chez les moyens parce
qu'elles sont restées très loyales très
chics très très tout ce qu'on aime quoi
alors il demande 50 millions à en beurre
et Amber le nombre sans briques
maison et tout ça alors qu'est-ce qui
lui reste à ce parce que ça m'intéresse
beaucoup de savoir ce qu'il a déjà perdu
en fait je voulais arrêter ça me rassure
il a tout perdu il a tout perdu d'un
point de vue pécunier il a tout point de
vue tout perdu d'un point de vue images
aussi il est très loin
de cette petite fille et puis ton image
qui est injuste pour l'instant c'est que
apparemment rien n'est prouvé quoi il
aurait frappé voilà cogner sur Non mais
il y a eu quand même des comportements
addictifs il était il prend beaucoup de
médicaments il a pris un peu de drogue
et un peu d'alcool oui beaucoup d'alcool
voilà reconnu qu'elle avait un problème
psychologique
quand même mais si Disney la virée de
pirates
c'est parce que ils ne correspond plus à
l'image pour moi Johnny Depp c'était une
icône et quand je vois ça moi je l'ai
toujours défendu mais ce qu'il a fait à
Vanessa Paradis franchement c'est
dégueulasse il a reconnu lui-même que
son mariage était une grande série de
danse et de poudre blanc donc il le
reconnait la poudre blanche
[Applaudissements]
Enzo et moi j'avais pris la même chambre
je savais pas que c'était la chambre de
sa paradis enfin je l'ai su donc je l'ai
j'ai compris que c'était prête mais
surtout il avait gravé le nom de son
fils sur le mur et ben oui quand ils
sont au nom de sa fille
Lily-Rose absolument oh mais oui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait Charles Camilla
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ça dans le
tronc d'un arbre il les avait gravé
leurs initiales
t'inquiète c'est pas ah non c'est
possible ou plus rien sur Johnny Depp et
ça ce sera la fin du procès la photo je
pense de Johnny Depp et on a vu les
photos
il a pris un peu de poids aussi hein
vous savez il ressemble fort à Marlon
Brando
il est tellement en galère de d'argent
qu'il a supplié Disney pour récupérer
son rôle de Jack Sparrow dans disons
conclusion des Pirates des Caraïbes
déjanté enfin c'est pas très gênant
qu'il soit non son image médiatique qui
était renvoyé
quand même ouais avec le personnage
merci Sabine quand même vous êtes là
Sabine et ça je suis désolé mais ça va
être personnage donc on continue
c'est quand même triste d'en arriver à
ça quoi après la carrière qu'ils ont eu
et la chance qu'ils ont eu les
possibilités qu'ils ont eu d'arriver à
ça
[Applaudissements]